66 million years ago an asteroid as big
as Mount Everest was headed on a deadly
Collision Course with Earth
the impact was so devastating that it
wiped out the most gigantic deadliest
reptiles to ever roam our planet
but the dinosaurs didn't just die from
one big boom no they faced a slow
agonizing end
how did this Extinction event cause the
largest tsunami Earth has ever seen
and what exactly happened after the big
reptiles were gone
Hold On Tight we're taking you on the
most epic and deadly trip of your life
this dinosaur ending asteroid is
terrifying Not only was it about 10
kilometers in diameter but it also
traveled incredibly fast between 10 and
30 kilometers per second
at this point it was a blazing Fireball
as it hurtled down to earth the air in
front of it was compressing and heating
up to unimaginably hot temperatures
just before the impact the asteroid
could have been as hot as the surface of
the Sun
once it entered our atmosphere it only
took this massive Space Rock a few
seconds to reach Earth's surface
and alter the course of life forever
as the asteroids slammed into Earth off
the coast of where Mexico is now it sent
huge amounts of debris up into the air
the shocking blast wave killed
everything in its way and from here it
was only getting worse yeah 66 million
years ago Earth was going through some
rough times now right now our planet's
not facing a giant asteroid but we are
facing increasingly severe environmental
crises if you think it's time to fix our
planet well stick around for a fantastic
video recommendation from our friends at
Planet wild you don't want to miss it
this powerful blast ejected bits of the
Earth's surface into the atmosphere and
minutes later scorching hot pieces of
glass and rock rained back down some of
the debris reacted with the atmosphere
causing acid rain that would last for
years
the land was burning the fires caused by
this devastating impact spread across
the continent like literal Wildfire
killing more and more Life along the way
and then just when you thought the
apocalyptic scenario couldn't get any
more intense
well it did
the impact of the asteroid hitting Earth
was so powerful that it sent shock waves
through the planet
and all that energy had to go somewhere
cue the mega tsunami
a wall of water over 10 meters high
raced across the ocean
this wasn't your regular tsunami it was
a staggering thirty thousand times more
powerful than anything you see today
as this monstrous wave spread across the
North Atlantic and South Pacific
coastlines didn't stand a chance the
wave hit with such force that it
destroyed and reshaped the continent
if you were there to witness this
apocalyptic destruction well you
wouldn't survive any of it but some
dinosaurs did
yeah the ones further away from Ground
Zero weren't immediately obliterated by
the impact they weren't incinerated by
the resulting infernos and they managed
to avoid being Swept Away by the mega
tsunami but still their fate was sealed
as the dust began to settle it was the
start of a nuclear winter even though it
wasn't nuclear weapons that caused it
the effect was the same
the massive amount of debris in the air
blocked the sunlight for months maybe
even years Earth suddenly became a cold
dark place and the Dinos weren't ready
for it
as temperatures plummeted and fires
released enormous amounts of greenhouse
gases the climate changed dramatically
plants weren't able to perform
photosynthesis and most of them started
to die out
this disrupted the food chain and
starved many of the animals that
survived the impact
and remember the acid rain it lasted for
several years causing more Devastation
to the ecosystems the oceans became too
acidic for marine life most ocean
species didn't have the time to adapt to
such a drastic change
these prolonged harsh conditions
together with the initial blast pushed
about 75 of Earth's life to Extinction
the good news is is that this included
the horrifying T-Rex
yeah as much as I feel bad for this guy
I'm happy he's not running around today
[Music]
when the last of the dinosaurs breathed
their last breath Earth became an empty
devastated Place cold and acidic
so when did things get back to normal
yeah well here's the thing
they didn't not dinosaur era normal
anyway
Earth didn't rebuild after that it
reinvented itself
one thousand years later the planet was
recovering from the post-apocalyptic
winter
it was still cold and food was still
scarce but life was ready to make a
comeback
in this new Wild World a few furry
Little Critters were sprinting around
among the first plants to reappear after
the impact were ferns they really hit it
off well after the disaster
000 years later Earth began to get a
little more lively creatures about the
size of raccoons were repopulating the
continents and the oceans were once
again teeming with life
fast forward about 10 million years and
Earth had finally restored its
biodiversity only it wasn't the same
Earth as it used to be now it was the
age of mammals
yeah after the dinosaurs checked out
mammals were on fire
yeah not literally of course
mammals together with birds and
flowering plants were rocking the planet
yeah Earth never got back to its old
self
after the last dinosaur died it took our
planet millions of years to bounce back
in a new way
but don't get me wrong this world was
still pretty terrifying it had beasts
like para Sarah therium roaming the land
and megalodons reigning Terror in the
oceans
yeah it's really for the best that most
of these creatures aren't around these
days
you wouldn't want to face a Meg when
you're out there swimming in the ocean
[Music]
even without bloodthirsty Megs sneaking
around the oceans today's earth and its
natural environments face a lot of
problems but it's not game over for our
planet just yet check out this new
YouTube channel Planet wild these guys
are like real life Avengers going out
there to protect our planet only instead
of fighting other worldly threats they
stay on this planet and get their hands
dirty rewilding it and fixing the damage
we've done to our home every month they
release a video in these ones here they
clean up the ocean from Deep Sea waste
or transform a dying Forest into a
beautiful strong ecosystem it's an
absolutely inspiring Journey one that'll
make you feel like you want to change
the world
big shout out to Planet wild for doing
amazing work and for encouraging all of
us to do better don't wait check them
out let's let's save the planet and not
go extinct like the dinosaurs
foreign